[Music]
and welcome back everybody to another
awesome episode of the careful boys and
today we have a very special guest mr
andy wing is in the building
and correct me am i wrong if people
don't know you uh you are
the empire builder of after's ice cream
love that place yeah that's what that
yeah that's what people like to call me
big fan big fan but before after his ice
cream you were in the clothing industry
right yep yep i did a clothing brand
called i'm king for seven years before
that our paths crossed
in the early 2000s when um the whole
like asian youtube world was barely
coming up and then i realized like there
was a lot of asian like dudes in the
streetwear game that was doing dope [ __ ]
and in the early ages of youtube
we didn't know anything about
sponsorships and [ __ ] like that so we
went to this place called orange county
you might have heard of it
um
so off camera western medical center
specifically thank you for that
information welcome
so off camera we were talking about like
these different brands and i just
connected the dots like oh [ __ ] dude
like you were um so i named one of the
companies i am king and you're like that
was me i'm like that was you that's so
[ __ ] dope
he said i am queen with me
all right orissue orissa
because i remember that brand because it
sponsored our friends [ __ ] um fairies
movement [ __ ] like that sponsored quest
crew too quest crew
yeah and then and then we weren't
officially sponsored but all the stuff
they couldn't sell they gave to us that
was so civic that was so amazing we
actually worked really closely with uh
franco shade yeah with joe and chris
yeah and they gave us all kinds of
[ __ ] gear and then uh also a triumvir
and they would give us
all kinds of gear too and it was just
crazy that like oc was kind of like the
breeding ground of all these brands
there's a video i got when we visited
trying um trying veer and then they had
a box of like stuff they couldn't sell
because they wasn't going and then you
put it on all you did was put on the
[ __ ] red jacket and they sold out of
it that's crazy richard which is the
co-founder of time bear we still work
together to this day and when we're
three right now i remember reaching away
yeah yeah he's that tall asian dude yeah
yeah yeah
damn how um so was i am king the first
business you started no i i i dropped
out at 19 and my best friends convinced
me to become a real estate appraiser and
i had no idea what the hell wow crazier
no real estate i didn't know
entrepreneurship meant and i didn't know
what real estate meant the only thing
was i was already in probation in
community college and i was like yo my
best friend was like hey let's go start
our own company i was like are you
talking about like we're 18 years old
it's not possible he goes well we just
do what this guy's doing i'm working for
him right now we'll just learn what he
does and start our own brand
so we ended up starting a real estate
appraisal company and
at an early age i was you know learning
how to make you know we're making three
hundred to three thousand dollars a day
so you're you're 18 19. yeah 19 years
old when i dropped out first job what do
you just appraising homes
do you need to be like certified to do
that to uh you got to take all the
courses take the real estate appraisal
courses and the appraisal test was was
one of the hardest real estate tests at
that time oh what year was this this was
2003 2004 when i was so the boom before
the crash yeah and i think i officially
got my license in 2005
uh but i left around 2008
but at the time of the crash because all
the regulations changed so how long did
you run that for until
uh about three years three years so you
see so 18 19 you already have seven
figure business
technique around a little bit with
devices you're spending it at the time
i'm learning how to spend it dad you
were balling at like 19 20
when i wasn't keeping up that money
wasn't going in my pocket i was going
back into the business and that's the
goal dude and the [ __ ]
wait you psyched you just cycled back so
an appraiser appraisal company i'm
interested like three grand a day right
like if you're making that money how
like what are your costs like to build
there's not really much cost clipboards
yeah mostly
clipboards and pencils we were working
in my parents garage at the time because
i didn't i didn't know how to even go
acquire get an office space at least i
didn't know any of that wow and had this
real estate appraisal license and going
out doing these files and
looking looking like this and you know
learning about business lingo how to
build a business you know getting people
to trust us to do it
and one of the one of the loan officers
we worked with happened to be chris no
so chris was a loan officer and he was
giving me files and i was working back
and forth with chris
um
and crystal leveraged chris no he was
like he was in [ __ ] real estate
officer what the [ __ ] why does that name
sound familiar so he uh when we work
that so he's like a apparel
manufacturing mogul now in the oc but
when we were working with franco shade
he was just the sales guy there yeah oh
he left sprinkle shade and went to work
under um king as a sales rep and i'm
king so he's he's he's like now in the
the now he runs the apparel game he's
just wow like [ __ ] like he has a giant
big-ass warehouse with like 30 different
brands that go to like department stores
and all kinds of crazy ass places wow
that's tight so then what changed from
doing that to clothing um so michael who
was the founder of urisu
one day he had he had a different brand
before that before reese's called
accentuate
and he needed someone to be in the
lookbook photo shoot and he asked me to
do it i was like no i'm not doing it the
hell no and he goes i'll give you free
clothes i was like okay fine what are
you like to model and then look in the
lookbook i was like
and then after that he's like i need to
get an office space and i was like you
want to get off the space together so we
end up getting this tiny space like
this size of the room this part of the
room right here
and he's doing his clothing thing start
getting ready to start racing one side
and i'm doing the real estate thing on
the other side whoa you can see my
attention span just like i was like hey
he's not making money but what he's
doing is way cooler than what i'm
i'd rather be doing that looks more fun
huh yeah and i was like even though i'm
making money i'd rather be working in
this clothing thing with you so then
when did the real estate thing go like
you you're gonna stop this and you're
gonna go full-on like clothing
the crash changed everything because oh
the the banks started requiring
appraisers to have to go you have to
work under banks and then all these
regulations so you can already see
everyone stop you using us and we're
like okay well we have to go full force
into the clothing down figure this out
i see
because it was like way harder now to be
like a certified appraiser or whatever
damn so
out of force you're just like well [ __ ]
it and there's like all these houses
that no one's buying anyway because of
the crash so then you're like well let's
get into close
we're just like teetering like our foot
when what one in the out the other so
we're just doing both at the same time
as we were getting less and less files
we were just trying to ramp up the
clothing side oh damn
specifically
at that time i was already transitioning
to i'm king at that time at that time
and that's your brand like you made i am
king yeah so first you partnered up with
your buddy for a reason i worked i
worked for him i just helped him as an
oh
okay and we're in the same office while
doing my real estate thing yeah so we're
just in this one room and then you built
your own brand i am king is this 2008
2009
i started the i'm king brand in 2007.
2007 2007. oh wow
that's when jk started that's crazy 2007
yeah that's when most like asian [ __ ]
started like all day we weren't that
serious though
we were 2007 serious either thought in
2007. they were invented
damn that's tight dude what what
happened to i am king so i'm king we did
that for seven years you know we're
selling to
the tillie zoomies you know with metro
park did it get in there metro park
didn't pay for a like a large six-figure
order yeah they fought chapter 11 and
they were going through some [ __ ] right
geez being that early on and not getting
that six figure check is is it hits you
and we're sitting with all this like
product in the world like what do we do
with this and trying to figure it out
how many brands were you a part of
during that time
um i just owned that i'm king brand at
that time that's all that's all i
focused on for that time period
but you know in apparel you see brands
come and go and trends like change so
fast and i think trying to chase that
and being dictated by stores on how to
design
um kind of turned me off after a while
you know after you do it for so long
like hey i need to figure something else
out and
as a clothing as a streetwear brand
owner though you learn so many different
skills right you're not just designing
now you're marketing branding logistics
sales shipping um storytelling because
everyone's blogging every brand had a
blog yeah
that was huge yeah i had to learn pretty
much learn how to become a writer dude
500.
he started made us like bobby's like set
the tone like hey y'all everyone has to
learn how to be a writer now how's that
okay well i guess i have to be a
photographer and [ __ ] man i know
the thing is bobby is a writer so he
sets the bar really high because he's a
[ __ ] journalist copywriter and then
so now he's [ __ ] writing all
beautifully and [ __ ] and then he got
everyone else got [ __ ] out of school
it's like
[ __ ] we're like i did a zanga before buy
my clothes cause it's cool dawg
d-a-w-g
dog look up to the streetwear event i
wasn't invited to i took some photos
check it out bobby's actually gonna come
here soon
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yo i tried to copy your blogs
word for work tight man so what happened
with i am keen did you end up selling or
just like this i sold it i sold it a
year after i launched uh after ice cream
so i was doing both the same thing again
doing both at the same time um and the
reason why i even went into so i have no
background food before that i've never
worked a day in my life in food i don't
know how to cook till this day i still
don't know how to cook yeah i don't know
how i'm even here but
i was vlogging all the time i pretty
much had to figure out things to talk
about so i just got writing about lunch
all the time here this is where we're
eating at throughout little saigon these
are my top places i like to eat at and
then people started
sending emails like hey those are the
that's the best places i've ever eaten
yeah so i just became this food
discovery person over time last time
we were on your
blog
so it became more of a food blog
a lot of different stores but food just
became a hot topic on that page and then
as i started traveling and discovering
more food i started noticing like hey
all these there's all these stores
outside of orange county that have
amazing
artisanal flavors right those things
i've never seen but i was like i didn't
know you could turn these flavors into
ice cream so i was like okay well this
is not approachable to me i'm just gonna
draw some ideas i have in my head and
things that are flavors that i think i
grew up with are more approachable and
and come up with this concept so i kind
of pitched what were some of the flavors
vietnamese coffee vietnamese coffee
that's one of our favorites
we love this one yeah jasmine milk tea
cause i drink boba yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
we did you know we did this cookie
monster with the blue ice cream yeah oh
i saw that one um that was a delicious
one so we made that became our number
one flavor by far by our partner who who
was working on it didn't want to make it
blue for the first week he wouldn't even
make it blue why because he's like i
don't think it was any blue ice cream
i'm like i'm telling you you need to
make it blue that did hella make your
mouth blue afternoon it's like the best
yeah
oh there's so many blue yeah i just ate
that at k-town night market like a few
weeks ago dude that one's hella long
last week how about that dude oh yeah i
ate there tomorrow all right dude all
right
making it blue was like a genius move
because it made it funny too like
especially for kids oh yeah kids love
that [ __ ] especially for adults yeah i
love it but unless you see someone on
instagram and they're like what yeah
what is this when you go in like i want
the blue one that i saw that ties a lot
into the street the stuff that we picked
up from the street where right things
looking good on camera yeah instagram
friendly and
we're a lot of those things that were
bringing in lifestyle into food and no
one was doing at that time so
that that flavor ends up selling 10
times more than any other flavor to this
day like and he was like i don't want to
make it
the first week he wouldn't make it like
you need to make it blue like yeah
that's it can i ask how much you sold i
am king for
uh soda for a
mid six figure mark at the time
just to just to just get out just get
out of it just get out so they just
bought all the inventory or whatever
yeah they just took all the branding
they didn't take any inventory we
actually um inventory we sold off
already
um was it a um franchise or did you own
all the shops
for from king yeah oh no sorry i mean i
was thinking about afters yeah i'm not
saying king oh okay okay i'm king so
they just they just picked up the pretty
much the the logo and the brands of the
hang of it hang on like all the ip
they're they're supposed to to this day
they still haven't done anything with it
so this button just held on to it was it
like a clothing controller
no it's just a private group that wanted
it that thought that like a vc group was
it karma loop regular pro no private
loop like a private asian group of
friends friends of friends that we knew
that what they just bought it they
bought it and then did nothing well they
wanted me to come back and re direct
director for a year i was like okay i'll
help for a year but then they couldn't
get their team together so i was like
that's pretty is that that's pretty
common huh that like some asian thing
just buys your [ __ ] and just don't do
anything yeah they still don't know what
to do with it or they don't hop for i
know there's major companies like uh my
friend was a part of um uh black flies
remember that uh sunglass and he was
telling me like yo i don't know how
they're keeping this afloat because it
it loses money every [ __ ] year and
then i was like
like i thought that brand was a bunch of
like white dudes that are skaters
they're like nah it's actually a
japanese company that owns it and it's
this massive conglomerate that's been
around for like a hundred years right
and then like they just [ __ ] buy
businesses internationally and he goes
like i think this is a wash like i think
they just buy business for other reasons
like they don't care about if it makes
money it's just the data or whatever it
is and i was like damn you do that with
a lot of restaurant concepts too in the
um right here in the middle east they'll
just buy it just to flex on each other
and then they'll so put the put the
signage up on the store but they never
opened it just there
yeah that's dope
how do they find you or do you find them
the people that buy your companies
i think it's a little i think over time
it depends on where you're at like if
you have a hot the hot concept
everyone's reaching out to you oh so
you're just getting offers through yeah
everyone's like all the vc guys all
these these private equity groups are
just reaching out trying to talk to you
trying to find out you know
yeah have you sold another company
outside of iron king
i recently exited out of afters so oh
you did yeah just like about two months
oh before how much is that
how much blue ice cream
i'm living okay right now
that's good that's good my kids will be
okay damn you want my kids to be okay
too
[Laughter]
were you soul or did you have a team
crafters yeah there's there's five of us
amongst the company oh okay there's a
lot a lot of us the reason being was
uh you know i started with two of my
friends one of my partners ron king
another person i grew up with and then
the partners that we end up teaming with
they own
the ice cream original ice cream shop
before we came there so they're like
these two older white dudes so they're
called afters ice cream no they were
called lola's ice cream and deli before
oh and until you bought the concept with
them or how did that we originally tried
to buy them out because we're like hey
you guys are open once every other week
can we just like take over your store
yeah open this
wait they're only open once every other
week yeah they had money right there
there's just once every other week so
they were scheduled so they did it for
fun it's just different fun they did it
for lola yeah yeah lola's grandma so
that's what i did that's why oh yeah and
then um
it took like six months to negotiate
this deal trying to convince these old
white guys that we were going to change
the game but why why this is it because
they already had a network or like you
could have just started your own concept
i think we were trying to keep the risk
as low as possible because we didn't
know the ice we didn't know that so you
wanted partners that knew what they were
doing we didn't team up with them for
that we teamed up with them because they
knew they're like we still want to make
ice cream and we're like i don't want to
make ice cream i don't know how to do it
oh it's not what i'm i'm not that's not
my expertise you figure this out i'll
just tell you what i'm looking for what
i want you you create it and that's the
guy that didn't want to make it blue
yeah well they're old you said yeah
they're older
what's the um
how did you guys come up with the
after's name the actor's name well we're
looking for a dessert term we found this
term like in some parts of europe they
call it like after a meal like dessert
like the word after is like after after
anything after eating out but absolutely
after so we just named it afterwards
what about the branding because it's
like it's all black and like sleek
looking so it's almost like anti what
you would think appetizing but it works
so good yeah so we we actually picked
that up from where the elements of
streetwear all over again at that time
period was um
street golf was popular right kanye all
black leathers um us following
the
east laurent stores the apple store is
minimalism so that's why we try to keep
that look we have like a lot of black
walls with like funny quotes on it like
our first store had gucci mane loves
afters when we you know we put that on
there because you have the ice cream oh
yeah
we're like hey he's not gonna do
anything he was in jail
but
use it while he's in jail that's [ __ ]
funny dude just martha stewart loves
this
is after chopper loves it is it was it a
franchise no we we we uh it was all
privately owned all privately owned all
of them and
we built that first location
or what we turned it around for like
using like 15 grand how many locations
do you guys have holy how many there's
20 28 locations
in california or mostly south
southern california and then one in los
angeles and how many mobile operations
are there there's three trucks that run
wow
see i i know one it's a cool location
but it's never opened in pasadena it
looks like an old derriere gastric that
location kills nah it's always open dude
kills it is it that's about my crib
that's where he goes that's his local
one
i was like when are they gonna open and
then maybe it's the time i'm i'm there
it's always packed too really really is
that alhamdulillah still open my still
open mystery yeah yeah we [ __ ] shut
that block down all right god we shut
that down oh yeah you guys are gonna
collapse that's right how did that come
ops had to pull up and stuff like that
and there was like a helicopter
stop the [ __ ] what was it like a king
james
after his collab grand opening after so
i think that was already a huge buzz
right everybody on main street it's
[ __ ] amazing who put that together
that was a good idea so they already had
the store grand opening and then i think
we were in talks with him with ben
because i know that you're close with
ben uh so we were talking for a long
time about trying to figure something
out and then when the main street uh
location was about to open up that just
made the most sense and once everything
started to come together you know we
created the flavor we had our boy chef
rob rob came in oh sure with the flavor
and stuff yeah there was like a kindest
flavor right yeah yeah yeah just
flavored like black sesame flavor
thank you thank you i support it
um but no it's all that we had a t-shirt
capsule and a hat as well that all sold
out that was done i didn't buy the other
stuff i just bought that timing was
perfect though because it was right
after you guys been to the show yeah the
timing was crazy i was gonna come by and
then i heard it was still packed like
i'm like it was like it wasn't you know
the long lines it was like
long and thick and all the way down
wrapped around the corners it wrapped on
the block and i was like i didn't know
that like cops would actually pull up to
this thinking that it was like a
[ __ ] would they come in like
you want to show support
they're coming by they're like where's
the blue one
they just light up and start doing the
trick
we didn't have i don't think any of us
have the expectation of being like that
because we had to push back the
performance like yeah like
did we just do it in the middle of the
street now it's too crazy that's great
you guys performed uh at the store yeah
just a couple guys had to like like
[ __ ] move a small little crowd and
then everybody's literally just
freestyling the video's still up uh and
it's just that's tight and [ __ ] i just
might text man i was like hey you guys
need to get here because it's getting
crazy and there's a helicopter's flying
around right now that's just dope man
they're freaking the city's freaking
they didn't know what's going on i
didn't know
right
dude you know um we recently did um
we did a jk news on this nft restaurant
and then um i was like i'm gonna go
visit it right and it was so crazy
because like i didn't know so your your
partner kevin we're friends and i had no
idea that that was his place too
yeah because he doesn't like like i mean
like you know like kevin's just like oh
just doing his thing with food and [ __ ]
like he's not like a big like look at my
[ __ ] you know he's so humble right
so i saw him um at a plaza one day and
he goes oh yeah yeah that's uh that's
you should come to my shop and i'm like
your shop goes yeah it's an nft shop and
i'm like that's yours and then so i find
out that you two are involved with it
and i see like i i i click the page i
check it out snoop dogg's down like what
the [ __ ] is all of this going on
and i went and did a food review there
it was [ __ ] delicious i was it was
pretty cool it felt it was like
mcdonald's and in and out had a baby
that's how it kind of tastes like yeah
yeah but yeah man is that your like main
project right now the nfts and the the
restaurant yeah we're we're
we're trying to save the restaurant
industry and and a lot of things that we
learned in the last year and how to
implement a lot of new this blockchain
technology into what we're doing that
sounds crazy you just said save the
restaurant industry what does that mean
uh what i learned through
last year was last september when during
the pandemic when everyone's still
getting free money right
i thought
when you when you're going out you saw
now hiring signs everywhere yeah this is
crazy i'm in the hospitality business
and i can't even provide good service to
the customer anymore this this is i
don't want to do this for the next but
there's no way i can continue to do this
this is going to happen
and september hit i was like hey
everyone's going to have to start
working applying for jobs and working
again september hits it gets even worse
i was like man those people are working
this is this this sucks
that's not what i want to do i was like
hey i need to i get i need to figure out
how to get an influx of money so i can
really really like uh do cool [ __ ] i was
like i've already done things
uh bottlenecked because the budget's
always been super tight but if i could
have a little bit more flexibility i'd
go crazy and i started learning about
like how people raise money in tech
and in tech you have these tech
investors go hey i'm gonna throw
hundreds of million dollars ten ten
different companies if nine of them
failed they're like whatever
yeah do that [ __ ] i was like there's no
way you can do that there's no way
unless i start doing like an app for
right now i'm not doing i don't want to
do an app i don't like raising money
it's not my thing let me figure
something out and then kevin comes to me
and goes
you can do everything that you want to
do
with nfts that's that's what i think you
can do and i was like what are you
talking about and once i started going
down this rabbit hole this web 3 thing i
learned about community brand building
marketing i was like i'm already doing
that in the physical space
but now if i bring this to the digital
space like you know some crazy things
that happen yeah and that's you know
seeing what gary v did with his fly fish
restaurants like dude this guy just
raised 21 million dollars for a
restaurant new york and it's not even
open yet that's not fair man that's not
fair man
you don't even want to start a
restaurant in terms of like
like you're like you're competing
gary's restaurant he can open the best
real estate best build out he can pay he
can overpay his staff and not even serve
a single dish and still be just fine
profitable
because he already has the money i get
that and i'm raising through customers
and building brand community if i can do
that through
this this space then
and if i can take i'm the guinea pig and
i take the league lead and this works
out it's going to change it for
everybody yeah
so it's being funded by board ape and
like nfts no so that that's just part of
it our food fighters nfc is another
project that connects to it oh
morton hungry thing it was just to make
a statement it was only to it was only
supposed to be a pop-up for 90 days
oh okay is that because you know we
didn't web 3's they're very sensitive in
this world right there's so much money
involved like there's a lot of scams
going on so we created board and hungry
because
we wanted to if we jump into the nfts i
don't want to just walk in the industry
and be like [ __ ] that andy you already
make money why are you coming into art
industry okay i was like yeah i'm going
to provide a gift to you guys this is
i'm going to build an in real life
experience because everyone's always
talking about like can you do something
in real life with these nfts and board
ape was the most popular thing at the
time everyone in the world and our
celebrity was getting one every other
week you saw it right i was like i'm
going to go buy this thing i'll buy this
thing and i know i what i learned is you
can use the ip and you can put it on
whatever you want anything yeah you have
to pay any royalty you have to ask any
approvals and i already because yours
personally i don't know about how to use
that utilize ip already because i've
done a lot of brand collaborations
it's like it's like pretty much saying
like if i bought a nike shoe and now i
can go open a nike restaurant you know
how valuable that is so i was like i'm
gonna do that with this board ape thing
so how does your restaurant work is it
like you eat monkeys
like do you so you have the board ape
and then do other people have to own it
or have a piece of it to eat at the
restaurant or no so um you know we're
using a lot of the the
the characters um to put on the store
and packaging to build a brand of ip but
you can also pay in crypto payments
which you know no one's really doing so
you can accept um ethereum and eight
point we're the first uh
first business to accept eight point
period yeah i mean uh board april's even
doing that they didn't know what to do
with that yet so they were calling us
like hey how'd you guys do that whoa
yeah so and then um you're helping the
whole industry by being like adopt like
early adopters and then trying to get
people to utilize it for you to like all
that absolutely and then if you're a
holder in the grand opening day if you
were a holder uh you had your own ape if
you verified it then you got a free meal
that day you know so different perks
that you can play with
what's your iq like 500 yeah
kicked out of high school i was filling
all my classes in high school i was
probation condo oh my god academics is
definitely not my thing that's [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh man that's so cool and sometimes
people just need to have a good enough
idea but the more so the balls to get
out there and i feel like andy does a
great job of like just getting in front
of like the pack you know what i mean
that's tight that's a big ball and
sometimes it's not about like yeah
that's a brilliant idea sometimes it's
like damn that's idea maybe somebody
could have thought of but didn't have
the ability to do another trigger on it
yeah you know front runner of that kind
of stuff so that's dope man yeah the
asian thing is trying to be first in the
asian community before we stop can we
talk about food fighters universe
food fighters universe is our nft
project so we
are the first nft backed restaurant
group that's where we start you know
we're trying to um
open a lot of different restaurant
concepts within the nfts that we've the
money that we raise
but we're always trying to do cooler
concepts and also
be able to help people that want to
start up their own restaurants like some
people like they go to they spend tons
of money going to restaurant school
right culinary school yeah and they come
out thinking i'm gonna go open my own
amazing restaurant but they end up
working in these kitchens and they're
just chopping salad up you know doing
salads like three four years and they're
like what did i sign up for but that's
what you get [ __ ] when they're
on kitchen nightmares exactly like we're
culinary school's a scam but go chop
some cabbage but we're we're around so
much talent and we we do have we do have
a platform and voice that we can help
you know
help people launch their careers that's
[ __ ] cool man that's tight dude
we're into food too but this video is
about you
you